the hopes of over a hundred thousand
people hang on the contents
of this small refrigerated bag
medics emergency crews and police walk
the precious contents of this special
christmas delivery into the papa
giovanni hospital
the kovid 19 vaccine has arrived in
bergamo
this city devastated by the pandemic is
learning to breathe again
it's early days of course but the
vaccination process has begun
the symbolic first dose is given to the
city's doctors
looking after patients and their medical
carers
is a priority here
these scenes are a far cry from the near
chaos that engulfed the emergency rooms
of this hospital and shocked the world
in march
after the most difficult 10 months in
medical living memory
the frontline staff like the head of
emergencies
roberto costantini are relishing the
future
today is a historical day for the human
being because
it's the first big step
towards the uh
to win to win the battle against the
virus
before before we had all only to
to react to the city measures
up and down according to the to the
measures but
but now we have the hope to to turn
the page and think of the future
the beautiful old city of bergamo towers
over its modern
sibling both were engulfed by the virus
and thousands died here
the survivors like serena and michael
part of the at-risk population
hunker down in isolation they're more
italy and most of europe are still
struggling with covet
the vaccination program now being rolled
out across the continent
is at last giving space for the
country's leaders
to plan for the future it's a real
turning point
because we we now we we truly
can can think
due to the exit of this pandemic
we truly plan the recovery time the time
of
uh or of the restart
we know that we will have to wait for a
few months
and probably we will have to face the
third wave
but we we now we have a big hope
we we see the light at the end of the
tunnel
finally 2020 has given everyone
something to celebrate
perhaps those who risk their lives for
others
can celebrate the most stuart ramsey sky
news